new details are emerging this morning in
connection with a string of unexplained
shootings at a popular campsite along
southern california's malibu coast
police are now considering a possible
link between last week's deadly attack
on a man while he was sleeping and seven
other unsolved shootings Carter Evans
reports investigators still aren't
talking a week after the fatal shooting
of a father camping at Malibu Creek
State Park detectives were back looking
for evidence tristan Beaudette was
killed while sleeping in a tent with his
daughters ages 2 and 4 according to the
LA Times he was shot in the head
although there is no known motive for
the killing homicide detectives
confirmed seven other shootings in the
area dating back to November 2016
these are shotgun pellets
yeah it's bird shots James Rodgers was
shot in the arm while sleeping at a
campsite nearby I think there should
have an officer staked out here to be
honest at night since most of these
attacks have come at night
Rodgers doesn't feel safe here anymore
and he believes the shooter may have
been aiming to kill him I kind of
assumed they were aiming for my head to
be honest others are now speaking out
the owner of this Tesla says his car was
shot while he was driving near the park
at around 4:00 in the morning just four
days before Beaudette was killed and
Melissa tangelo had a similar experience
while she was camping in her SUV they
all say they feel like their reports
weren't taken seriously the Sheriff's
Department is not responded to our
repeated requests for an interview but
on Friday released a statement saying a
link between the past shootings and the
murder will be explored the park
stretches over more than 12 square miles
in the Santa Monica Mountains and while
the campground is closed indefinitely
the park remains open to hikers and
families looking for a spot to cool off
there are warnings posted here for
everything from rattlesnakes to poison
oak but there's nothing about the
shootings and that's unacceptable to
many park visitors there was a family
from Maryland who just came by they
didn't know that there was a killing
down here and he could be out here but
there's no warnings or anything posted
up it's just you kind of have to find
out on your own you know for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Calabasas
California